let's get some clarity on a variety of
issues from our dr. David agus who's
gonna join us from his home in Los
Angeles dr. agus good morning I want to
begin with something that came out of
the white house coronavirus briefing
yesterday the President himself said he
did not think we need widespread testing
that seems to contradict the advice of
many of his medical experts from your
perspective from where you're sitting
what do we need to have in place from a
testing perspective before we lift these
sort of social distancing guidelines at
the end of the month we're gonna need
three things Tony I mean one is we're
gonna need the ability to do millions of
tests a week and that word was write
millions of tests when we open up
they're still going to be cases we also
need to do what we call immune
surveillance that is a blood test to see
whether you actually had the virus or
not so not whether you have it that's
the DNA test or the RNA test but
actually whether you have it and then
the third is we need to do social
tracing that is we need the ability if
you do test positive to go back and say
who did you interact with over the last
few days because those people need to be
kept at home and so when you have three
of them in place in low numbers of cases
we're gonna be able to let people out in
a graded way and we're gonna get back to
a new normal but we need those in place
how much progress have we made to having
those in place I mean are they in place
today well we're getting a booking
capacity of tests we're not there yet
with testing who has the virus we
certainly have a ways to go you know
there was data that the Abbott machines
are out there but not everybody is using
them yet so the infrastructure needs to
grow to do the test the test for who had
the virus in the past tense that blood
test we're nowhere with it we really
have not scaled that across the country
yet and there are a couple of small
tests that are being done but very
little the idea of social tracing we're
gonna have to talk about privacy issues
going forward do you need to know who I
interact with over the last two days I
think you do to actually do true social
distancing require teeing of those
individuals and to do it right so those
conversations have to start happening
now and the technologies have to be
scaled well on the subject of immunity
what are we learning
whether once you've had this if you
recover can you get it a second time
it's a great question and there was data
that came out of South Korea that showed
that individuals who had it tested
negative twice then tested positive
again so was it wrong test was that a
false negative on the test did the virus
reactivate the answer is we just don't
know there's a separate study out of
China which I think was really
illuminating in that they looked at the
level of immunity in the blood of people
and about 30 percent didn't have enough
immunity after they recovered from the
virus and most of those were the younger
ones who had the milder symptoms so what
does that mean in the scale of things we
just don't know yet and those studies
while they're in South Korea and China
we need them to be done here in the
United States it's time now we started
to do our own studies and had our own
data so we can make the right decisions
based on that data all right dr. David
agus progress clearly has been made but
there is still more ground to cover
appreciate your perfective this morning